liebe Freunde der gepflegten
standertime normalerweise heißt es bei
Muskelprotzen ja hier oben hui da unten
na ja bei flying uve ist das aber ganz
anders seht selbst und nicht vergessen
wenn ihr mehr von ihm sehen wollt
abonnieren ja du kennst es das sind die
Lose das Fragen Lotto darau freue ich
mich schon den ganzen Tag gut das ist
das auch das Glas was sogar Bushido mal
in der Hand hatte oder so ich glaube ja
außer ist man zwischendurch kaputt
gegangen nicht hatte der glaub
alle haben das in Hand
gehabt okay ja bitte ja darf ich alle so
du darfst auch alle natürlich ma nach
aber wegen der Spannung machen wir rotot
grün rotün alle also jürendres konnte
ich noch drei Fragen z. stellen weil das
hätte noch wir hätten noch Tage ach dann
mache ich natürlich du aber hier auch
zusamm gedüdelt
hier mach dir dein proletenhaftes
Benehmen nicht manchmal Schwierigkeiten
proletenhaft win ich proletenha ja ich
also es gibt ja so ein Ereignis wie
Ereignis du warst ja mal Mr Hamburg ja
aber bist dann rausgeflogen ja ach hier
die ja ich meine ich habe eine große
Fresse ne also ich rede gern und was ich
damals gesagt habe oder warum ich mein
mrok Titel verloren habe habe ich
vollkommen Recht und wieso was hast den
da gesagt ich weiß es nicht mehr was
acho für die Leute die es gar nicht
wissen h was war da ich war ja ein Big
brotherus uh leider und ja
Sexy Cora die leider verstorben ist sehr
jung bei allem Respekt aber ich hatte
mit ihr ein Gespräch und dann ging es
darum ich habe sie gefragt warum hast du
denn keine Ausbildung gemacht anständig
man auch nicht sagen mein
Pornodarstellerin ist auch ein Beruf ja
mein wer guckt kein Pornos wenn er
alleine ist und Single
ist da ging es darum wegen der
Ausbildung ich habe sie gefragt sagt sie
nee sie hat eine Ausbildung angefangen
und
da habe ich sie gefragt und auch zu Ende
gemacht unds abgeschlossen ja nee ich
sag was hast du den eigentlich gemacht
ja ich glaub Altenpflegerin war das IR
nee Krankenschwester genau und D sagt
sie ja konnte ich dann aber nicht
weitermachen weil wegen Rücken und
Hüftprobleme da muss man manchmal auch
schwer heben sagt sie D habe ich aber zu
ihr gesagt ich sag aber bumsen geht oder
was mein stell mal vor du machst Doggy
Style in huhekreuz geht das nicht auf
die Hüften und Rücken so und dadurch den
haben wir in der Zeitung in der
Bildzeitung Morgenpost hat auch noch ein
Artikel drüber gewonnt habe ich dadurch
den Titel verloren ich fand den Artikel
aber richtig geil so Hamburger Jung mit
einer offenen Schnauze ich mein das bin
halt ich kann man das poletenhaft nennen
nö ich bin selbstbewusst und
mus sind rote Fragen ja aber ich finde
die gut die ist in
Ordnung passiert sowas öfter dass du was
sagst und es ah du ärgerst dich nachher
m manchmal manchmal habe ich oder meine
Freundin sag Bo Schatz das war aber
heftig so D sag ich ja meinst du ja okay
ein bisschen anders hätte man das machen
können so ja ach ja und dann habe ich
ihn noch verloren weil wo ich gewonnen
hatte die Scherpe um hatte kam noch so
ein so so einer wie du Internet
Interview und so und da war ich mit
meiner Freundin auseinander genau das
war die Geschichte deswegen mit groupy
ähm kam er denn an ja was machen was
machen Sie denn jetzt und so habe ich
gesagt ich gehe jetzt zu meiner
Ex-Freundin und Vögel sie so richtig
durch D sagt er ja aber wenn sie nicht
will ich sag das ist mir egal dann nehme
ich meine Scherpe und bin sie ans Bett
Fessel sie dann natürlich hätte man das
sagen können werde mal zu meiner
exfundin Rennen und wird Sie mal so
richtig verwöhen oder so na man kann
sich ein bisschen anders ausdrücken das
habe ich wirklich gelernt das muss ich
sagen also das habe ich wirklich so aber
in der US fragekiste wenn ich ein GCK
Rei denn manchmal muss ich dann doch mal
mit so offenem Wort so aber das habe ich
wirklich gelernt so ein bisschen sich
anständig artikulieren und ja ja okay
nächste Frage das wieder eine rote
wieder rote wollte sagen rotgrünit alle
jede Frage beantwortet wird findest du
es nicht total peinlich was ach so
coverby auf der Zeitschrift schwulissimo
zu sein mus ich den Namen mal auf der
Zunge zergehen lassen Schw der Name ist
echt richtig g
richtig genau auf solche Fragen habe ich
geantwortet kommt noch so eine Fr Frage
wie Uwe bist du schwul oder so oder nein
nein das ist nicht das ist nicht dabei
ich glaube nicht dass Schw auf so eine
Frage habe ich gewartet die ist auch
wirklich berechtig alles kein Thema was
war das peinlich ja heute denke ich
schon so oh ja okay aber meine einstell
ich mache das halt deswegen ich war auch
mal das war letztes Jahr vorletztes Jahr
oder so da gab's oder es gibt immer
einmal im Jahr so eine große
schwulenmesse gayvenion heißt s glaube
ich so und da war ich einmal richtig so
dieses plakatgesicht ne kein Kinofilm
Plakat mit guck Action Film ja war halt
ein Plakat für die schwulenmesse so und
die haben mich halt gefragt oder uns in
Agentur bla W Uwe wird das machen und
habe ich natürlich gedacht so okay
damals mit 18 da war ich 18 oder 19 nee
19 war ich da da haben sie mir das Bild
für die Schul das Cover das war gar kein
Shooting extra dafür das war mein erstes
Test Shooting wegen der Modelagentur
ersten Bilder müssen gemacht werden und
dann wollten sie das Bild abkaufen ja
cool kauft mal ab da was für a Schul der
Name klingt echt
geay so so gedacht okay ich mach's
trotzdem warum ich das gemacht habe
jetzt kommt jetzt ist kommt der Grund
denn ich finde auch Schwule sind normale
Menschen für mich also ich habe auch in
der schwulenbah mal gearbeitet nein
nicht als als Stricher oder cboy wie das
denn als spkeeper so und da habe ich
wirklich mal die schwulen kennengelernt
was sind Schwule für Leute ja was sind
Schwule für Leute ganz normale Leute so
und ich muss
sagen die besten Künstler ja Musiker
oder Fotografen auch in der Filmszene ne
so
oder die die Modeleute die ganzen
schwulen ohne den ohne die schwulen
Leuten da wird sowas gar nicht weil die
schwulen sind echt auch wahre Künstler
ja und meine Einstellung ist halt ich
sag mir schwule was soll ich jetzt auch
zu jedem Türken oder der schwarze ist zu
Alberto mein Kumpel S auch e du bist
schwarz e wie einige sagen [__] weißt
du nee du bist ich s do nicht zum
schwulen da jetzt so ja nee du du
fix du fixer junge wolltest du du du du
da die Jungs da in da unten ins Braune
Loch da weißt du ich
meine warum hat jetzt Mann Anus wo eine
Prostata drin ist und durch den Anus und
jetzt mal ein bisschen sexual und Kunde
hier kann man auch zum Orgasmus kommen
man hat doch der liebe Gott nicht so
einfach in den Raum geschmissen hat doch
schon alles sein Sinn nein es gibt ja
auch Tieren also ich meine wer wer
Homosexualität als pervers bezeichnet
der hat irgendwie Biologie nicht aufge
der größte schwachsin aber trotzdem ich
würde die Frage ja auch einem schwulen
Stellen der sich küssend mit einer Frau
auf irgendeinem Frauenmagazin ablichten
W auch komisch ist auch vollkommen ja
natürlich deswegen du bist ich sag mal
es hat hat das nicht folgen reden
sprechen dich da nicht an hey hallo ich
lese das immer ganz oft auf mein ich
lade ein Video hoch wenn das Video auf
der Startseite ist nutzen dass die
userus oh guck mal Uwe ist hier ein Bild
schwulmesse gay Gesicht und so weißt du
die haben den Text auf der Internetseite
auch ein bisschen komisch geschrieben
der schwule Bruder mit seiner Freundin
abgeklärt und so das Shooting ganz
komisch geschrieben so ne diese
Aufmerksamkeit er jetzt ein Bekannter
Youtuber nutzen wir das mal aus bin ich
ein bisschen zätzen von denen aber ich
stehe dazu und ich habe es halt gemacht
weil ich eine gewisse Toleranz zeigen
will so ganz einfach was ich natürlich
nicht an schwule mag ist auch vielleicht
Ansichtssache ich habe ja in der
schwulenwe spber gearbeitet da habe ich
so kenengelt es gibt schwule Leute die
machen richtig auf [__] die sagen es
auch in der schwulen Szene so ein
Schwuler s zu e mach mal nicht auf [__]
hier so weißt du so weil die hab sieht
aus wie ein Typ ist auch ein Typ und
macht aber und die Stimme verstellen
entweder man ist eine Transsexuelle man
will eine Frau sein dann ist es auch
okay oder man ist halt ein Typ der
schwul ist aber man muss nicht so weißt
du so das mag ich nicht wenn dieses
verstellte so denn noch so gehen das mag
ist das verstellt oder ist das für die
echt das frage ich mich immer aber wir
kommen vom Thema ab ja ich weiß es auch
nicht aber nee also peinlich ist mir das
nicht ich stehe dazu ich will sagen jo
wir sind alle gleich ob schwul ob
schwarz ob Türke ob Chinese jetzt sagen
eine du kannst kan schwule nicht mit
Nationalität vergleichen natürlich kann
ich das klar kann ich das ist wir sind
alle gleich auch schwul und ist do alles
okay was ist los schwule Zahlen auch
Steuern die gehen hier arbeiten die
große Frage gibt immer ja das ist ja
nicht normal aber was ist normal es gibt
ja nichts normales du bist nicht normal
ich bin nicht normal keiner ist normal
das ist ist halt so ne ist mir nicht
peinlich no mal die Anw gut okay sehr
schön ich muss ich denke jetzt immer
reingucken weil eben haben wir da mit
dem iPod jetzt musst aber mal grünes
was macht dich so einzigartig da muss
ich sagen jeder von uns du bist
einzigartig ja und der Kameramann da ist
auch einzigartig äh jeder ist auf seiner
eigenen Art einzigartig und was mich
einzigartig macht ist wohl so dieser
Hamburger Jung mit der offenen Schnauze
der Kampfkünstler mm und ja so der Uwe
halt ne okay ja ich muss mal doch mal
hier bitte
ja was haben wir denn
hier
woher hast du dein Selbstbewusstsein ja
es habe mich kein Witz vor zwei Monaten
oder auch mal selber gefragt weil damals
ich war klein schwach dünn und mein
Problem war damals immer als ich damals
von meinen Stiefvater Ärger gekriegt
habe ich musste immer weinen ganz
komisch das war so da war ich 12 13 auch
noch ich musste immer irgendwie weinen
ich weiß nicht warum habe ich ein
richtigen Einlauf gekriegt und ich
musste dann weinen ich habe es gehasst
und heute ist das anders ich kriegen
Einlauf ich muss grinsen so ich weiß
nicht so und woher nehme ich mein
Selbstbewusstsein ich denke mal das hat
echt wirklich die Kampfkunst aus mir so
gemacht dadurch habe ich durch die
Kampfkunst habe ich wirklich erfahren
was für ein starker junger Mann ich
eigentlich bin von der Einstellung her
und vom Körperlichen können ich denke
das macht mich so
selbst wenn ich das richtig
interpretiere ist am Kampfsport auch das
Training ja der der Psyche im genau weil
z.B meine braungurprüfung z.B die ging
seinhalb Stunden die hab hab mich
körperlich und psychisch richtig
rangenommen so ist auch Sinn der Prüfung
ne entweder du willst Kampfkünstler
werden doch gewisse Dinge aushalten kann
oder du lässt das
nach und nach jeder so einer Prüfung
oder nach jedem Training weißt du ganz
genau e heute habe ich richtig bin ich
habe geschrieben beim Training die
Muskeln haben gebrannt ich konnte
eigentlich nicht mehr ich habe aber
weitergemacht und das macht dich auch so
selbstbewusst das macht dich ja zum
Kämpfer du kämpst gegen dich selber
eigentlich gegen deinen Körper sozusagen
du willst aber dein Körper will nicht
und dann sagst du aber e Kollege
scheißegal sieh zu mach und dann
Schleich du dich daadurch und kannst
nicht mehr und das mach ich denke ich
mal so selbstbewus so ist das bei mir so
also dass man Grenzen überwindet die man
eigentlich als gegeben sieht aber die
überschreitet man und denkt wow ich kann
was genau nach meiner Brun Prüfung
dachte ich auch schon wieder ey mich
kann echt nichts mehr aufhalten das was
ich heute in den seinhalb Stunden
gemacht hat kann auch eine Rakete
angeflogen kommen die weiche ich aus so
das ist echt das ist so ist das dann
irgendwie ja nächstes super nächstes
wieder eine
rote
was machst du in 30 Jahren fragezeig
Model WD dann ja langsam schwierig ja
ich will nach 30 Jahren auch kein Model
mehr sein modeln ist auch für mich so
ich könnte mehr in den Bereich machen
ich tu es aber irgendwie nicht weil weiß
nicht mein Ding ist eh YouTube und ja
aber verdient man da nicht wahnsinig
gutus die hat die hat sich da ich glaub
Haus von ja oder ich hab auch für Adidas
mal da gibt echt richtig geile Kohle so
aber ich mach lieber Youtube Videos so
ja ist viel geiler so stelle ich mich
hin und mach meine kampffilme oder so
dazu muss man mal sagen bei Youtube gibt
es weitem nicht so viel zu verdienen wie
beim Modeln überhaupt nicht aber das
Ding ist ja wenn ich ein Youtube Video
ma kann ich mich hinstellen wie ich will
und Posen wie ich will und so sein ich
bin dann der uweel Model macht mir auch
Spaß klar aber ich renne nicht zu
Agentur mach car mache ich gar nicht so
die kommen immer irgendwie zu mir durch
mein Agenten da du hast hier willst du
was für die schwulen wieder machen so
oder für adidas oder wie auch immer so
so kommt das so aber ich habe ja ein
Beruf gelernt das sollten ja die Jungs
und Mädels da draußen auch tun deswegen
sage ich Schule Jugend sehr wichtig und
ich habe marlord Lackierer gelernt ich
bin ursprünglicher Handwerker auch
fertig auch fertig ja habe auch als
Geselle gearbeitet und so weiter und ja
wenn ich mal nach 30 Jahren wenn mein
Youtube Channel nicht mehr läuft oder
ich keine Filme dann drehe Actionfilme
kinoilme oder wenn ich keine Kung Fu
Schule mehr dann lass ich den Pinsel
wieder
schwingen mach s jetzt okay
green warum kommst du so sympathisch
rüber vielleicht liegt das daran so ich
denke mal oder weil ich halt so bin wie
ich bin hast du Laune ja das frag mich
auch mal ich muss auch Grenzen keine
Ahnung wo du da unten aus dem Auto hab
ich auch schon KR gegrinst so er ist
dalar cool ja das kommt auch von selbst
so manchmal ich echt muskelkader so das
zieht sich alles hoch oder ja warum soll
ich denn könnte ich jetzt auch machen
aber das wäre den nicht ich so weißt du
das bin dann nicht ich so dann ist das
so weil mit 13 wird noch nicht so
gewesen sein wenn du gesagt so wo ich
mit Kung Fu angefangen habe so glaub da
ging es dann auch so los dann hing das
hier du bist immer am grinsen ne ja so
das weiß ich nicht also eine schwere
Kindheit heißt nicht dass das eine Bürde
ist genau also das oder ist es eine
Bürde für dich nein ist keine Bürde nein
das macht GI sagen ja ich hab so eine
schwere warum geh ich hab schwere
Kindheit oh das Interview lief jetzt
gerade nicht so gut weil ich habe eine
schwere Kindheit ich musste gerade
wieder nachdenken größter schwachsin ich
gehört habe für mich jetzt so den ist er
wirklich von der Persönlichkeit wirklich
sehr schwach also hat er weiß nicht dann
da muss man auch wirklich viel an sich
arbeiten nee gerade deswegen vielleicht
so den keine Ahnung passiert da so n
erledige ich mal kurz damals habe ich
Sachen gehabt so die waren wesentlich
schwieriger vielleicht deswegen so weil
jetzt alles super alles perfekt so super
komm langsam zum Ende ja ich ma auch
schnell damit wir schön jeden Zettel
hier beantworten knen aber ja m gucken
ob noch rote oder grüne zum Schluss ach
so ja okay die Ken
wir willst du nicht mal einen
vernünftigen Beruf ausüben habe ich doch
ja ausüben me lackiera mach ja nicht
mehr jetzt bist du so am rumkungfu
Videos videchen bisschen
rummodelnum Biss paar Videos machen ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen YouTube ist
wirklich für mich ich habe mein Hobby
zum Beruf gemacht und ich muss sagen ich
habe wirklich ja also ich kann es so
sagen ich habe wirklich Youtube zu
meinem Beruf gemacht ich ich mag mein
Youtube Channel ich mag die Videos die
ich da ma und das ist auch wirklich aber
ich meint du ich habe heute morgen
gedacht e was du alles du jetzt du musst
die Leute ranol hier ein zwei dre
Kameras da und nach hier drei Lampen
stehen weil das ist ja du du musst
richtig viel machen du bist der
gearschte weil du musst noch mehr ackern
wie ich zum z.B okay aber meine Kung Fu
Filme meine martial art Filme ich muss
auch ich muss die Kamera hinstellen
vielen Dank danke schön ich muss die
Choreografie einstellen ich muss draußen
bei Wind und Wetter wir müssen uns warm
machen und alles zieht und ich muss da
mit meinem Bein auf dem Kopf rumwedeln
und so das ist alles Plan das ist
körperliche Arbeit das Schneiden ich
mache teilweise Nächte durch ja ich habe
noch eine Frau an meiner Seite ja die
will auch ein bisschen was von mir
abhaben ich habe noch mein Training das
ist alles Arbeit was sagen denn
eigentlich deine ich sag mal Schwieger
Eltern in spe dazu sagen die bist du
bescheuert eigentlich oder sagen die
deiner Freundin lass dir mal links
liegen nehmen wir mal einen ordentlichen
Mann ich mein zu Anfang hat man das
belächelt ne diese internetvos der macht
da irgendwas im Internet so aber heute
sehen sie so oh da kommen gute Sachen
und dann werden sie natürlich selber
drauf angespr ja guck mal der Uwe hier
ja da ist hier von ist mein
Schwiegersohn so schön so man merkt das
auch auch jetzt letzten war ein
spiegelbeitrag hier es wird langsam
ernst genommen es wird noch in den N
nächsten Jahr YouTube wird noch ein ganz
großes Ding werden da werd nicht mehr
hier bauersuch Frau geguckt oder lieber
youtube gucken weiß absolut ich guck
auch schon lange kein Fernsehen mehr
sonst würden wir nicht hier sitzen ich
bin auch ganz fest davon überzeugt es
werden die Leute werden flying ufe
gucken die werden Klick zum Gucken und
das wird nicht so ach das ist ja
Internet sondern das ist so hey das neue
Interview kommt raus oder hey neues
Trainingsvideo müssen wir unbedingt
sehen heiß auch nicht umsonst Channel
weiß Youtube Channel einfach ein Sender
so
weitermachen ich find aber super ich mir
macht das ein riesen Spaß mir
auch also noch mal ein Kompliment an
alle die bis hier durchgehalten haben
was macht dich so
attraktiv bin ich attraktiv ja was macht
mich so attraktiv ich denke mal
Ausstrahlung ist immer ganz wichtig wenn
ich ganzen Tag so durch die Gegend rin
wird natürlich scheiße macht ja nicht
attraktiv deswegen seid fröhlich
freundlich genießt euer Leben und geht
natürlich auch zum Sport ne ich sag
immer man hat ja nur einen Körper hätte
ich zwei Körper den einen hätte ich
richtig schön trainiert so wie so
einfach wie jetzt den anderen Körper
hätte ich schön auf Couch und vielleicht
noch mal Puff gehen ein bisschen was
bezahlen für Sex so richtig so das dirty
Leben so aber nein pflegt euren Körper
sage ich immer und das macht allein
schon attraktiv so aber Ausstrahlung ist
glaube ich schon Ausstrahlung ist das
zählt auch an erster Stelle es gibt echt
muss ich sagen habe ich vorgestern zu
meiner Freundin gesagt ich sag Schatz
guck mal die ist zwar dick die Frau aber
die ein hübsches Gesicht und einfach
eine geile Ausstrahlung ist freundlich
die ist intelligent hat ihre Röllchen
gehabt aber war trotzdem kann man so
sexy weißt ich me so ja ja natürlich
absolut das ist also Ausstrahlung meist
ist eigentlich Ausstrahlung na ich war
mal auf der bodybuildermesse da liefen
ja ganz viele voniner Sorte rum aber da
gab's halt wirklich Leute da half das
nichts die hatten keine Ausstrahlung die
guckten halt hatten da so ein Kopf oben
drauf der war wie ein Schluck Wasser ne
und dann ist das eben doof aber
vielleicht libt daran weil sie kein
Wasser meinem Körper to ausgelaucht sind
und sind froh wenn die dann noch aus der
Büne wieder
wegkommen was gibt dir beim Sport den
Antrieb weiter zu machen oh ganz da gib
echt ganz viele Sachen ganzz ganz kurz
der erste der erste Antrieb war mein
Vater Bruce Lee mein Sifu und jetzt ist
das der Antrieb ich will einfach der
beste werden ist schon immer ich will
der beste ich will Kampfkünstler werden
und du hast auch die chanenuf der beste
zu werden ist das realistisch oder gibt
es wie viel es gib deem gibt ja gibt's
viele besonmt aber
irgendwie ich sag immer ich bin es gibt
so ein Zitat so ich bin ich sage ich bin
nicht der Beste sondern ich würde aber
auch nicht sagen ich bin so einer von
den weißt du das kann ich jetzt aber
noch gar nicht so sagen weil ich bin
noch jung weißt du in 10 Jahren sehen
meine Schläge meine Bewegung noch
präziser geiler besser wirkungsvoller
aus undwas woll ich noch sagen zu dem
Thema Antrieb Antrieb ja Antrieb beste
zu werden der beste zu werden werden und
ja das gibt auch Leute die fragen mich
bist du gut bist so gut kan haust du die
Leute um und so da sage ich auch nicht
so oder ich sag immer zuud dem wenn ich
jetzt sage ich bin gut denkst du ich bin
Angeber ja aber wenn ich sag ich bin nee
ich bin nicht so gut dann weiß er ganz
genau ich lüge weiß du was soll ich denn
da jetzt noch sagen so deswegen scheiß
auf solche Fragen so von we also mit wie
gut bist du bist du der beste ich sagte
W sag wenn mich einer nach meinem
Fähigkeiten fragt wobei ich halt SAS
habe ich nicht si was ich mach ja nicht
ganz Scheiße ja genau sage ich das ich
bin nicht so ganz so schlecht so rot
hier die letzte
Frage wie gehst du mit deiner
Selbstverliebtheit um oh süß eine
gemeine
unterstellungel
selstverliebt selbstverliebt nicht aber
man soll sich schon selber irgendwie gut
finden also ich gehe wenn ich jetzt
morgens aufstehe zum Spiegel sei es
nackt oder mit Unterhose gucke ich mich
an und sag ich bin gar nicht so hässlich
geilen Körper irgendwie also der ist
trainiert so was will ich mehr da unten
baumelt auch was auch nicht zu kurz
geraten und ja gut ich habe haausfall
das war so zu Anfang dachte ich so nein
haausfall scheiße und so aber ich
schneid sie jetzt kurz und einige sagen
ich sehe aus wie W Diesel Jason we ich
se wie sagt man hübsche Gesichter
brauchen
Platz das klingt jetzt arrogant aber so
Macken muss man schon haben ne aber
selbstverliebt bin ich nicht aber ich
finde mich nicht hössig und das finde
ich auch sehr wichtig das auch gehört
wieder zum Selbstbewusstsein dazu man
weiß man ist nicht hässlich und so
präsentiert man sich dann auch und ja
wie ich damit umgehe ist ja ich finde
mich in Ordnung das muss man noch haben
man muss s schon so ein bisschen lieben
kann man aber nicht wie Michael Wendler
der ja jeen Morg jeden Morgen vorm
Spiegel steht und sagt ich bin geil das
aber natürlich schon für die Kamera
kannst was du willst kenne mich
okay ja ja gut man wei nicht eine Frage
hat mir jetzt gefehlt
oderag wel fr ich anabol ja die hatte
ich auch immer im Kopf dachte aber
eigentlich ist die doof aber die machen
wir jetzt du nimmst jetzt einfach
diesen jetzt so als wird die Frage drauf
stehen bitte schön
UBE nimmst du
Anabolika ich muss sagen das ist sowas
ist für mich das ist das geilste
Kompliment was ich kriegen kann so
nimmst du anabolicaa auch teilweise in
den Studio wenn ich in anderen Studios
bin oder so die sehen mich aber nimmst
Anabolika oder heimlich kriege ich zu
zeichen so du machst do den Knall oder
das für mich echt ein geiles Kompliment
wenn einer sagt zu mir u nimmst
Anabolika weil ich bin Kung Fu Kämpfer
und ich ma Fitness so ja ich ma Fitness
und bin natural Bodybuilder ich weiß gar
ob man zu mir Bodybuilder sagen kann
aber nein nehme ich nicht ich esse schön
viel Eiweiß und nim mein Shake und mach
Sport und mach mein Kung Fu das bringt
mich zum Erfolg nein ich nehme kein
anaboliker es ist ja auch ich habe mal
ja Kollegen ja nicht von dir aber es ist
eigentlich kein Regel sondern der hat es
halt mit anabolicaa war so ein Schrank
und das rauptproblem bei anabolica so
wie ich es verstanden habe ist ja da du
hast viel zu große Muskeln für dein
knochenestellt das heißt du zerstörst
dich das ist noch nicht mal das ich Ken
ich kenne einen der hat ein ich weiß gar
nicht ob ich sagen darf aber ist egal
ich sag nicht wer es ist ich kenne einen
Rapper der hat sich so den Arm gebrochen
okay beim Arm drücken okay so nach dem
Motto das war jetzt nicht dein Arm doch
doch nein doch doch also und das ist
aber du meinst nicht das Hauptproblem
sondern ich kenne einen der ist der hat
mit 16 damit angefangen der nimmt's
immer noch und der sieht so scheiße aus
der sieht so Wasser wässerig aus dem
schießt das Blut in den Arm dann hat er
da irgendwelche Verstopfung das Herz
wird natürlich und ja und das wird
glaube ich auch relativ klein das wird
auch klein ja da habe ich auch schon mit
Leuten gesprochen die sagen ja mein mein
mein Hoden ist kleiner geworden geben
das noch zu du merkst es dann auch ganz
schnell wenn jemand da seine Kuren hat
dann wä er wieder inaktiver nach dre
Wochen kommt er wieder ein Studio denkst
was mit dir denn passiert e bisschen so
dünn geworden so das sind natürlich die
Leute die natürlich den Stoffen man sagt
immer so er nimmt Stoff oder mein
einziger Stoff den ich nehme ist
heftiger Stoff der heißt HT hartes
Training okay das ist mein Stoff den ich
habe und das bringt mich zum Erfolg kein
Anabolika HT gut gibt's auch nicht in
der Apotheke oder so kriegst du nur von
dir selbst
ja das waren die Fragen das waren die
Fragen ja cool ST hat Spaß gemacht ja
das freut mich dann viel noch viel HT
wünsche ich dir ganz und dir auch ne gut
vielen Dank das war super cool
sensationell